back to school means buses are back on
the road and we want everyone to be safe
this semester here with back to school
safety tips is glenn simpson with
community ambulance welcome to the show
hey good afternoon so are most of the
incidents involving buses what are the
incidents that are happening out there
yeah so obviously kids are back in
school buses are back out buses are
moving again and typically what we see
is the children within the ages of four
to seven
they're typically walking and they're
the ones that are involved in either
unfortunately an injury or or death or
as a result of this oh my gosh
now for parents and drivers anyone out
there what are some tips we should
adhere to this semester yeah so it's
obviously been a little bit since our
kids have been back in school so they're
back walking they're back getting you
know getting their selves back to school
and they're doing that various ways
they're
you know we want to remind folks to to
take their time when they're out in the
school zone in those school areas kids
are walking kids are crossing the street
and so we want to be make sure that
they're being extra cautious
if you're in a school zone avoid backing
up don't want to back up in those areas
kids are unpredictable you don't always
see the kids and we don't want to we
don't want to hit them what's the rule
with it with the school bus that stops
the arm comes out there's a stop sign
and you're on the other side
should you stop every time or does the
divider come into play if you stop or
not yeah always always a difficult
question and i think i even question it
myself when i'm when i'm going down the
road but what's important is if you see
kids crossing come to a stop right let's
get the kids get across the street
always wait for that last kid you know
to get out and get across the street and
just we want to be extra cautious in
those around those areas now parents
what are some tips that you give to
parents whose kids are heading back to
school right now yeah so a couple tips
that we want to remind parents is
plan your routes make sure your kids
know the route to school and how to get
back home
that way if you know you weren't just
you know if your kid wasn't home at a
certain time you can take those same
routes and try to find them
make sure you check their clothing as
they're heading out some kids are
leaving really early so it's still a
little dark out and so maybe some
reflective clothing will help them
also make sure they're wearing a helmet
right kids these days are on scooters
they're even still on the heelys and
they're on bikes and make sure they wear
in their helmet so that if they do hit
their head that they're well protected
they're protected and we were talking
about something before the show about
making eye contact and that's very
important i think for the driver and the
student as well explain more yeah i
think i think that rule applies to
everyone children and adults right when
we're in a crosswalk it take that extra
moment to make sure that eye contact is
being made simple way to ensure that eye
contact is being made is wave at the
wave of the person i do that when i jog
around the neighborhood just you see
someone you think they see you but
they're paying attention sometimes to
their phone their radio or something
else last question you mentioned uh
before the show that id bracelets for
students to wear what's this
yeah so you know if your kid does have
any sort of known medical problems or
any medical history and there is an
incident as healthcare providers we want
to know what those instances are so when
as our paramedics arrive on scene
that little id band can give us some
immediate information to know what we're
dealing with and it also gives us a way
to contact the parents so including uh
in case of emergency contact on that
it's great stuff great as well glenn we
appreciate it thank you so much thanks
for having us rocky we'll send it over
to